he very well could have set up a trap in
the opening I remember once against
aronian in Norway chess he trapped Club
on screen in the English opening and I
think he'd spent an hour 20 minutes at
that point and it was clearly just a
trap
and you mean he was still in his
preparation yeah I think he's a small
prep wow
and I didn't understand that at first I
only realized it after talking to
svidler and he said yeah I was a trap
and that was like a light bulb moment
for me after that I'm thinking every
time grishek is taking long in the
opening yeah it's a trap
so in in that game did he spend that
hour 20 did he spend half of it just
pretending to think do you think it was
just double checking all his variations
or just enjoying the moment I mean yeah
it was probably just enjoying it
wow